is
are women from foreign countries better
wives than the ones
we currently have let's let's not let's
not limit it to Great Britain in the
West in general
are women better wives
let's go for a guy Banksy what do you
say
um well I've been recommending this for
a long time that men in the west due to
a myriad of reasons should start looking
elsewhere I spoke to a gentleman in
Australia about four years ago in
regards to him he was a pilot he had all
his house everything paid fully like
stacked a man was rich handsome and
generally you know in that top what what
you guys call the 10 10 20 and he
categorically told me that when he is
ready to get married he is going to get
married to a lady or a wife where he's
going to find them either in Vietnam
Cambodia Philippines and a country like
that he's in Australia himself very
wealthy in Australia but he will not
bring his wife to Australia he will
marry her and he will stay with her and
build a life in that country because he
knows that if he brings her to Australia
ultimately the feminists in Australia
will corrupt her and thus she'll be
looking for for for the extra the door
within a few years possibly a Visa
situation so in order to counteract any
of that he will marry in his 50s but he
will keep her in that country where the
laws are much more favorable in the
divorce courts to the men wow oh ladies
what do you think about us
um
so do you feel that like he
she's gonna actually be marrying him
because she loves him and desires him or
that she just truly wants to get out of
the country or the poverty that she may
be living in to get to Australia to
wherever you were saying that she what
like he's from he's really wealthy so
he's then gonna like keep her in a
little box in the country that she's
trying to maybe get away from just so
that in order so he can control that
situation
do British women marry more for love you
think
I mean I feel that women automatically
marry from a place of feeling rather
than logic most obviously there's the
difference between logic and emotion and
the ram women that are more pragmatic
but I think generally women do go I
think we're into it I mean I think women
marry out of opportunity although so my
question is if so they why is the
average marriage seven to eight years
and why is the number one reason they
leave Financial if women in the west
Americas well because men are meant to
be the provider if we're going back to
what everyone says we're meant to be
virgins
that's true it's true but at the same
time if we're talking about the
polarities of the masculine and The
Feminine energy if you want your wife or
your partner to be in her feminine
energy when I say a provider she could
still be working she could still be
doing her thing but in his energy being
the provider so looking after and what's
the female energy is supposed to be in
her feminine obviously that doesn't mean
virginity but I mean it does
it means Purity that's what matters if
you look at the polarities of feminine
and masculine energy even in within
every single person in this room there
is feminine and masculine energy that
doesn't say Purity you're not any less
feminine because you're not a virgin are
you a virgin people wouldn't say no but
feminine I would say I would say I am
less feminine than I was like I was more
feminine when I was a virgin yeah I
definitely wasn't because every every
heartbreak makes you a little bit more
bitter oh I don't know
honest every every heartbreak comes with
some trauma at the same time the more
penises you have inside you the more
masculine you come yeah so I will I
would say I would say when I was a
virgin like I was like 100 but it
doesn't negate from the fact that you
are still able if you do the work to
step into your feminine energy if you're
with the counterpart that is in his
masculinity I just think women are
either feminine or they're not to me and
to me like you can learn to fake it but
like you'd be like but you can always
smell it no if you do if you do the true
work on allowing yourself when I had my
son that forced me into my feminine
energy what what is like the because no
offense I I just hear this like do the
work but then like there's no work there
is when you go to when you do you work
out why you're in your masculine energy
because there is always a why to
yourself so say I'm too masculine and
then so like I find out it's X reason
then what what do I do what's the work
therapy okay deep trauma work Shadow
work there's so many different things
sound bath here then Reiki here then
there's so many different types of work
that you can do therapy to maybe get
over your father wound which are your
mother wound which is usually where this
I need to be in my masculine energy in
order to prove something or even society
says
freezing yeah but this is they don't
sound like real things well I think
sometimes women can be quite masculine
because they have not met a man that has
allowed them to to be in their feminine
energy so sometimes times they feel like
you know they're not with the right man
that is allowing them to take a step
back and be in that feminine energy and
to like lead them ultimately so do you
think that femininity is conditional
then conditional like do you think that
it depends on the condition just like
masculinity no it's not because I've
seen many [ __ ] out here let me tell
you something as a man if I said I'll be
masculine for the right woman no no no
no you're gonna look at me and say what
you're gonna be like what do you mean
I'd be masculine for the right woman but
you say you'll be feminine for the right
man and you think that makes well
because he's meant to be the leader he's
a leader you're meant to lead so if
you're if you're you're meant to be in
your if I'm meant to be in my master I
think we have not meant to be in your
feminine yeah but I think we have
masculine and feminine energy and I
think if you're a woman and you're with
a man that doesn't allow you to step
into your femininity because he's not
masculine enough then you're masculine
side kind of comes out and compensates
for that
I disagree I just think that's an excuse
that women want to use as an excuse to
be masculine I I just think that's an
excuse like like the most
picture-perfect feminine woman I know it
doesn't matter who they're with they're
feminine regardless I just think you're
either feminine or you're not feminine
for starters I agree with what she just
what Paul just said but um
do you think it works both ways so
basically if you're uh slightly
masculine female
because you're not with the right guy
that can bring out your femininity do
you think
a man will get away with saying he's a
slightly feminine man because he's not
with the right woman yeah maybe a man
can be with a woman that's maybe a
little bit too masculine for him and
then it doesn't allow him that
confidence to step into his masculinity
it's all about that
the question is
would you give a guy who's very much in
his permanent energy a chance nope
probably not because I just feel like I
want a man to lead
because I'm sure that uh you know
females in their masculine energy would
like a man to give them a chance I mean
just imagine this imagine if a guy just
started like being like hey girl hey
girl and because he's like I wasn't that
I mean with some masculine females had a
lot like it's crazy like that would
sound nuts to you crazy but we can like
never fat spew this is like nonsense to
me I just think you're either a feminine
woman or you're not a feminine woman but
I think sometimes the thing is I'm sorry
there's a this is something where most
people who've done any kind of training
martial arts anything else they say you
are your habits you are what you train
if you train full contact you punch full
contact if you train semi-contact you
throw semiconduct you are your habits it
is incredibly difficult to live your
life for most of it or for decades as a
masculine woman and then suddenly turn
on the feminine but you can train it
though you can train yourself
but the thing is
does a man train you or do you train
yourself well it depends if you
relationships can bring out that side of
you to do that because a lot of the time
when you get into a relationship the
reflections and the trauma that is
brought up where then it forces you into
that space of like you know what
actually maybe I am not doing something
in this relationship that's not allowing
this man to do what he's meant to be
doing and so then it forces you to look
to get that mirror and be like you know
what I need to do the work on me sorry
outside of therapy what else
because I just imagine like if you're
gonna change your whole temperament like
there's a lot that's in it so I mean I'm
sure it take well no it does take many
years therapies that probably so not
outside outside the therapy
um
a lot of stuff I can't say I can't say I
wouldn't like to but do you think like
this is the thing about like women that
say this kind of stuff men here we don't
want masculine women no we don't want to
be massive we don't need that but what
I'm trying to say what I'm trying to say
is like you say oh we've got to train
ourselves to be feminine right
reprogrammed or reprogram yourself or
rejig yourself whatever it is get
yourself download a new program well
it's like going to the gym but men
generally don't they ain't got time for
it now if if it's the princess if if we
take you on a date for instance right
and we see that you're more masculine
than you are feminine we're already
calculating like this is going to be a
problem it's going to be a problem and I
haven't got time because I don't know
you like that we haven't got time to be
trying to program you and you're trying
to train you into being more
feminine like we want if we go on a date
with you we want a woman that we can see
she's kind of feminine I kind of like
this do you know what I mean and then
we'll pursue it but masculine women we
don't want to train you because if we
say the word because you use the word
train no I did it yeah but you said that
you asked me a question whether a man
can do can help you in that and so I I
didn't say because a lot of the work the
Deep work that I've done I've done on my
own not for like yes relationships have
presented these mirrors for me too which
every relationship presents mirrors
could be a relationship with your mum
your friends can present these spaces of
where you're like okay I've got to work
on myself in this and understand
sometimes you don't need to say this so
you don't need to say that or you can
take a step back and understand that yes
this man can lead me so I'm not saying
that it's a man's role or job to do that
that's a Twist of words do you think you
need a man to co-sign it though
and so like if you know you did this not
not just you but anyone that does like
the Deep work the femininity training
like would you say that there has to be
a man that co-signs it because like
women Lie To Each Other Well I think
that when you get into a relationship
you'll then when you take time out maybe
after a relationship and then I think a
relationship will let you know how
successful your deep work has been
because you're not going to know how
successful you're going to be in a
relationship so you're in a relationship
right so the thing is I wouldn't say a
man because you could be a lesbian this
is like Beyond cap
um
it's like the amount of cap here is like
or cope are you married
um I was engaged for a long time but the
thing is that's that what I see here is
like the women saying oh when I meet the
right guy I'll then turn it turn on the
femininity whilst actually in the
realities they don't actually even turn
on the femininity they just go you just
can't handle a strong woman yeah and
then you as a man are berated and
ridiculed because you can't handle this
incredibly masculine learn energy of
this woman that's coming at you all day
long because you don't want that you
want feminine submissive and beautiful
women and so that's I think part of the
reason why men in the west are actually
going abroad whether it be Dominican
Republic Brazil certain parts of Africa
um Eastern Europe
um Thailand Philippines that's why
they're going there to kind of find
wives because what what a lot of them
are saying and I've heard it a lot from
men that Western women are too much work
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible